parce que adam blues est un dealer
marseillais ce que vous rendez compte du
mal que vous faites à tous les jeunes
ils sont en souffrance et qui trouve
peut-être voilà un échappatoire dans la
drogue dans le est ce que vous pensez à
ça quand vous rentrez le soir chez vous
vous avez des remords non non un peu
inconnu parce que je force personne à
venir c'est je fais ça demande malgré
parce que c'est un mec que je vais
chercher l'argent sais pas j'attends
d'eux par l'argent dont vous pensé qu'à
l'argent
c'est l'argent facile quand tu fais de
tp de 10h à minuit des temps plein des
temps on va on va pas vous plaindre a
dit merci la soirée ya des gens qui
travaillent à l'usiné du corps avec
deezer et qui gagne 1200 euros par mois
et travaille comme comme des chiens je
suis sûr que gagner pas 1200 euros par
mois ademe deux fois plus maintenant
mais il n'y a pas deux fois plus il va
pas durer pour 2400 bras mais les brefs
et après vous êtes monter de grade ouah
c'est à dire c'est quoi les grades
ces guetteurs vendeurs gérant grands
gérants cette fière de vous et à des
marges pas faire mais pas fier
j'aimerais bien avoir un travail